now if I understand the story correctly
you heard about the making of the film
and you jumped on a plane you with no
hesitation I don't know if that's a
correct story but yeah do you remember
what that plane ride was like where's
the baggage yeah no storage it was a
cargo plane it's next to a goat okay
friendly goes friendly good hi friendly
goat so I saw this teaser trailer that
these two guys time and small and David
Lee had put together and they had been
with the family shooting for years and
really embedded themselves and become a
part of the family so they put this
teaser trailer together I saw it and a
couple days later I jumped on a plane to
go and you know meet the family and and
profess my my love for the story and you
know immediately I just was was taken
with Stephen Michelle I felt like I knew
you guys he mostly fell in love with me
yes I we played ping-pong almost
immediately after I sure yes to the
house so uh you know just being able to
to bond and and get to know each other
better was was I think crucial but
during that flight was there any type of
should I be doing this what if they what
if it's not a match I mean what was the
what were the voices in your head at
that point honestly from being totally
candid I I did not have any of those
voices I was very excited to come and
talk to them and I felt like there was a
so did a little bit of background my so
my father has been Muhammad Ali's lawyer
for 30 years and I had always been
wanting to tell a story about Muhammad
and his wife Lonnie and in seeing some
of this footage about Steve and Michelle
I saw some very strong parallels and I
just felt instantly even in that six
minute clip that like I knew how to tell
the story and I know that sounds perhaps
overconfident but i just wanted to go
down there and talk to them and show
them that that i was the the best person
to come on in and help bring her story
to the world and when he left what was
the conversation like
I like this guy I trust him oh I didn't
really care much about the movie part I
just liked him cause he played ping-pong
okay so I knew like okay guys yeah there
was a movie crew that was figuring out
the movie I was like no I liked him i
thinkI I liked his look and I liked his
clothes and I'd like to play ping-pong
with him Oh what did I where I don't
know what I watch is probably yours and
yeah probably the same thing yeah my
shoes by the way yeah he didn't really
see them but
you